house comb resumes beard back welcome
back to first light this might be the
last episode already but it's great
come join me she's she's stuck if I
couldn't make a deal how was I supposed
to get him back
excuse me how did you work out of that
tunnel did you get another power from
that mental son alright yeah I was
holding out on you again
yoga pants I'll show it to you just
clump up some guys down sorry sometimes
I just say whatever comes to mind
press r1 oh [ __ ] whoa
hello heat-seeking missile because it's
training it's working good
give me something tougher to fight then
she she promised she wouldn't she
wouldn't hold off any more at a tad
fights or whatever all right
let's kill some more people
sorry the card would who creates the
combat holograms he's obsessed with the
video game on that demons I'm a family
it's not a clip for training purposes
they'll push you to the limit
are we gonna fight those really really
sorry
oh god you're proper you crack ray stop
it
oh Allah damn I did it okay
she's just talking nonsense in the
background like oh yeah whatever you say
unlock the gamma arena survival mission
alright so I guess they want you to play
with this there's a future for conduits
who can put their past live perfect
roses Eddie quit their ass so tell me
how your story ends I'll actually finish
with that I tell you all the details
about Mohawk men without options I had
to go on the attack
problem was I didn't know where to find
him or my brother
is she dead I hope she's dead let's just
shoot her some more you know some more
where's Brett cool BIOSes cool guys wear
glasses no wait I was in Tucson search
the thugs for oh [ __ ] sorry
ah where my thug glasses at night so I
can that's riding my boob well that
about does it
sorry I don't know what's going on go to
the rear oh okay
one of these got it Oh a second you
cease for real for real y'all I'm coming
for you track okay you can ship drugs
without me track big mistake track do
you like bro fists truck defeat enemies
where Oh everyone got it man where you
going
all right boy what just happened I don't
know what just happened
good call hiding inside that thing you
still dead though that's the problem
about that hiding idea that you hiding
good bye hahaha that thing is my
favorite so awesome it's kind of freaky
going through those fences or whatever
destroy Shane's goods his junk or oh his
money and drugs Scott
I mean I could just use that money but
why do what why would i okay we need to
do a graffiti I'm Edie roses got it
almost yeah what is that a wizard whoa
Hadouken that [ __ ]
Oh what had a sex you for real I'm
answering oh sorry lady swear to God I
was not trying to brofist you that
gunfire are you for real you guys a
straight-up [ __ ] to read mentally
challenged that's what I said nothing
else sorry okay that it you think you
can run from Smosh as the greatest
sniper Sonic I don't even know what I am
anymore
it's kind of sad story I was adapting no
I wasn't don't like those I'm sorry
okay I'm sorry it's not a tickle people
and cars like Oh take off what do you do
away with that phone looks like i doing
on that car there you go that's better
here we go tag that [ __ ] attack we
still haven't got that like if you
remember from the first game bros like
we had this she she had this raid spray
or whatever that you could upgrade and
get I always wanted to try it cuz it
looked badass but you have to be evil in
the game to get it so it'd be cool if we
get it now I had this deal seems pretty
short does I'm worried that's gonna is
that oh nice there we go what do you
think I've been doing without him you
have no absolutely no protection from me
you can't afford for him to get a cold
what took her so [ __ ] long to get I
realize alright where are these trucks
man
come on surprise [ __ ] let me
brofist your car for you tagging time
let's do it bros what do we got this
time hopefully I feel like a naked
bearded man I don't know why I feel very
hour or an hour my dildo now it's oh
yeah bout that'll teach him
oh there's another one inside cool
alright let's just get it get get get
get get get a girl
it's a brofist run away for your life
they said come on
don't run you like brofist hey you go
here have one for free actually discount
five the only prize your death whoa
alright let's destroy the [ __ ] what are
you doing he may where's guard ever what
the [ __ ] that was almost awkward how bad
you were yes lay the [ __ ] down she was
all a favor
oh I'm Gigi yup I bite my ass suck my
ass suck my ass suck it
come on haters suck it guys like Oh
looks like you have a weak spot there
will be ashamed something happened
through it alright now we can take it
what are we get I'm gonna get a but that
is really cold what are you both kiss
okay change my mind into a dead rabbit
sad that eating a sandwich a hand
holding a sandwich hand burning money
almost got it almost had that one
I swear to God oh it's calling hello
samosas ding oh boy that sure was fun
haha BAM
how you give up that's cut your card
I'll save you as a pet
tagging time what do we got alright I'm
gonna guess a wolf that doesn't want to
drink an alcohol what do you browse
guess a deaf skull with a foot on it got
it now at a depth of that thing okay
last one got it oh wait you had no
you're wrong you think they might be
interested to learn what your cargo is
it's kind of federal offence illegal I
don't care about me all they're
interested in is the fries you're the
target
yes I'm sure they'll turn the other way
after they get what they want
let's check this out where is it there
it is far away but that's not a problem
from mitosis oh poor guy he just wanted
to have a normal life driving his truck
what a [ __ ] brofist everyone even the
barrels no way huh all right hi back
massage it's free goodbye gotta love
that slow-mo kick man it's freaking
amazing and by amazing I mean amazing
not just amazing just oh boo
it's like your face melts when you say
it oh oh what's shooting me but you
didn't have to shoot my weakness make it
like I wasn't happy and I shoot you with
it
sorry I tried more backup come on guys
oh the students this single arity there
we go
I'll save us some time everyone let's
part in this medal come on guys it'll be
great come on - guys wait oh wait this
is way more come on right hopefully the
dup one interfere what do we get this
time okay that's definitely a skull
dancing with two monkeys two drunken
monkeys what are you bursting alright so
far I'm right about nothing there we go
beautiful good job Russ did you get it
don't lie oh nice haircut looks flaming
hot yep that was a joke I'm not kidding
well I guess I am Shane anyone answer
your gang will be smaller than when I
started
although can one person even be a gang
crocodile you come and get me and I
swear on my mother's grave I will blow
your neon brains all over those walls
sounds fantastic I love it ah Shane's
hot out got it
should we go in here go to Shane's hot
add oh there's a bun I didn't see it
sorry beautiful far below oh what a
surprise drugging me is gonna keep me
from Brett
I shouldn't see a drug addict she should
be used to it oh we're not gonna make it
I deal with pretty stupid shade
so this is how we got cat oh my god this
is how we got kid no the drugs took over
jugs
okay whoa mom what the you trying to
hide this Abigail you hurt that girl
when you get angry you lose control your
father's right
it's for your own good coming up the dup
unloading me because I was a problem oh
hell no you should go it's a brand
what's the one defending huh
whoa freaky
this is great white hello
whoa drugs is a hell of a thing huh this
is game against drugs again maybe I
don't understand oh don't tell me that
light of let hold r2 got it
that's right
don't call me trash beautiful
hugging me is not gonna kill me
oh I'm so sorry
Oh Oh it's confusing shady Oh
how do you how do that even but I'm so
good huh oh oh hey hey hey
it's okay and that's where my men found
you it was Shane who took your brother
he's the one who put you there out of
control given the chance would you kill
him what is this
kind of then do it oh ah ah how do you
tell this gal that I am 100% normal
American I already knew you were stories
on her but I had to make you relive it
to get you back to the point where you
gave up David I'm not one of those
freaks
whoa damn so we didn't even get to
choose I thought we would have to choose
if we're gonna kill or not that's the
point of the infamous I've been duped by
the DUP garret hilarious best joke today
thank you
oh he didn't die he don't need nine or
here now
oh he but he won't die fire fight going
die as sure as I am looking good in yoga
pants he gonna die
when is the diet I wait to take but why
do we supposed to do with a target the
prisoners know ABC 39 west on 402
advising variegated Junction over heels
off [ __ ] he's mine
mmm feisty cool we get to chase after
Shane shades out the shame that sounds
kind of similar so it's funny right
gonna show you scepter Shane she's after
Shane we gonna shade scepter strain like
am bane hello we call the trails off the
truth girl will go - sorry I don't know
that looks about right dandelo doesn't
it
we escaped with three other guys sorry
two other guys hello
I don't think I did the right way huh oh
I thought you could actually grab the
medal or whatever stays a little faster
what what what what all right we did it
show you SAP Dechaine I don't have any
neon yeah give me neon place I don't
know why this reminds me a Borderlands 1
when you're near the vault up in the
mountains in kind of the end like I
don't know why maybe just me you
probably have no idea what I'm talking
about
uh okay do you pee only I guess I can't
go over there then bales you make it
anyway do ya
I was just the bridge it's an olive
adder there we go up we go not [ __ ] not
all the way huh guess we gotta climb
some more huh
oh that's okay I'm wearing yoga pants
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
piggy
don't turn on the sound side walk copy
drones at least help search but watch
out where you're driving
we're having trouble keeping them aloft
in the storm Nick :
go now oh my god
well nothing dose couldn't we get neon
from that one though come on come on
give me that knee on the knees come on
go be a good one all of them broken
their whole like malfunction in [ __ ]
come on give me some of that bu sugar
come on
don't run Oh God look I'm in a mess on
the map whoa how convenient
that's a word suck it up for the last
time oh you like it too
come on yeah I know you did it too you
didn't want to do it now then do it
that's pretty good ten out of ten would
snort again all right similary available
it's been great guys really great going
without God
[ __ ] yeah alright let's defeat the rest
boom done
what are you hello girl I want to punch
it I don't know why I thought I wasn't
good myself take it the neon while we
can yeah
never can go faced yeah only if
necessary yeah I just freaking destroy
their frickin thing I would think a I
don't even know
whoa hello ladies are you doing will I
missed you how ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
that chick is the best thing in the
world love it
goodbye boo let's kick this guy off the
ledge just for funsies why are you
scared
he's scared alright when I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a game or what not Armageddon I'm again
god you're paying attention too much
action for you oh I'm sorry
alright almost done Bruce we're almost
there oh [ __ ] well look at this cave
it's amazing if someone's like I'm
sliding I get it
yep did I get it I mean yes of course I
got it look whoa oh oh well that can't
be good
you think I can freaking fly and [ __ ]
nevermind I guess I don't have to oh god
there's the heli oh [ __ ]
go go go go go go go oh oh ah can't step
this I'm [ __ ] fabulous come on I just
want to party like Miley
oh wait that's not a good okay um I just
want to tell you that's better
yep this camera this camera whoa oh oh
that helmet hit me
Jesus look at that ha ha that's amazing
I made amazing a move Merc sorry
yoga pants yeah yeah yeah what
wait who are they shooting at this is
you thinking more about me at this point
oh so far none of you guys have stopped
me so I don't see how you think that's
gonna work well what the [ __ ] just
happened
I don't shoot my ass what is he doing
he keeps spinning oh my god I get that
neon please thank you
Sankhya it has some lasers here welcome
they're free
Oh God Jesus he was happy about it
all right we better get rid of the
helicopter
hey you girls demand marvellous get the
samosas oh all right let's keep calm
race you're doing great so proud of you
so proud checks up the shame yay geez
doctor taint ASA here we go
damn girl you look crazy
no he kept running come on Shane don't
you know I'm Sanok did he forget that
little detail all the sudden I can't
Sanok come on a little gust like a jump
whoa you're dead chain is over Shane
don't even dare talk to me what do you
say huh
by the way out of here you back off now
where else hi you're afraid to know
junkie oh I'm told that hurts yoga pants
so I have no choice in the matter all
right well poop great uh-oh
ut-oh
this is a price attack okay I'm holding
up
finish em
oh this right
whatever you want girl is long the way
those yoga paints weightless there
whoa that's [ __ ] epic
civilian target has been executed oh
whoa
she wanted us to do it because [ __ ] is
that oh it is Eugene wait what what is
she
well this is interesting and we are this
is how the fight in the game started
haha well we know the rest
that's pretty awesome
that's pretty [ __ ] cool name that
it's pretty sorry
know why I keep doing that voice uh yeah
that's so I wonder if they will make
like a DLC for every character like
Eugene and a bald guy and remember his
name
I mean they all seem to have like a
backstory Eugene was bullied the ball
guy had a baby wanted to take a bow to
Canada that's what they do in America I
suppose if you're fierce ki adalat
Landon yeah that was a fun deal see yeah
I I think I hope you boys enjoyed it as
well I had a lot of fun playing for you
bros as always it's always fun to hang
around with you bros do these little
things and I just want to say thank you
so much for watching you make make my
dreams come true early I can just stay
here and play games it's [ __ ] amazing
so thank you that's for your ladies
don't take it the wrong way
hey you're jealous that's for you boys
too alright this is getting awkward
I'm just want to wait out until this
it's credits
it's kind of hard keep talking so what
did you do today
I'm I'm serious I'm asking you
okay well that's very interesting I
didn't do that
but I bet you had your reasons for doing
what you did and I'm not one to judge
all right don't look at me in that weird
way
are you flooding me from that kiss come
on I know that was a bad god dammit you
notice there's all the pink that's going
on here
is that is that what's doing the magic
too much pink for you I bet it is bad it
is and I bet you like it you like a pink
just because it rhymes with a link the
band 182 I like them too
oh great I should probably just stop
talking all right
I'll just wait this out and we have the
playground to play run win it's actually
a lot of fun just [ __ ] around in this
game and there is a lot of [ __ ] to be
done but anyway thank you for watching
this video bros and this series in jello
thank you for leaving like I really
appreciate it and here's well for you
there's still like relax one brofist